c'est une couche additionnel pour
encourager les gens qui sont malades de
ne pas voyager pour à détecter certaines
personnes qui pourra avoir des symptômes
de crever 19
c'est une couche additionnel qui va
protéger les gens avec nous ou jacques
roy professeur titulaire et directeur du
carrefour logistique à hec montréal on
retrouve à granby montfort monsieur roy
bonsoir on va revenir brièvement sur
cette mesure aujourd'hui prise de
température obligatoire dorénavant
est-ce que ce sera suffisant pour
rassurer les voyageurs passent une
mesure de plus un qui s'ajoute aux
autres idéal mais ça nous prendrait un
vaccin mais bon défaut de vaccins de
médicaments miracles c'est une mesure
qui peut rassurer les voyageurs en plus
des mains du port du masque et de toutes
les époques sont faits pour nettoyer
toutes les surfaces des avions un site
web ont clairement l'expérience voyage
aérien et sur le poids de beaucoup
changé beaucoup de mouvements monsieur
roy dans l'aviation dans l'industrie
aérienne cette semaine on va revenir sur
transat qui va reprendre ses services le
23 juillet 23 destinations dans
l'impression que on reprend mais ça
risque d'être compliqué oui évidemment
au départ il faut que des gouvernements
participent donc qu'on puisse se
permettre aux voyageurs d'agrément de
reprendre l'avion dont coauteur du côté
des européens des américains qui
voudraient venir chez nous et des
canadiens et québécois qu'il faudrait
c'est rare en europe et d'un dandy des
destinations soleil
alors tous à examen est conditionnelle à
la réouverture on veut des messieurs oui
c'est ça et de toute façon est ce que
les voyageurs seront pas au rendez vous
ça c'est l'autre question
ouais tout à fait l'hypothèse qu'on
qu'on voit un peu partout des études
récentes en chine ont démontré que ce
sont davantage les plus jeunes voyageurs
qui sont non plus empressés à reprendre
l'avion chez les plus âgés puis on
définir pas c'est quoi les purges et mai
les gens sont beaucoup plus réfractaires
sont plus en attente de être davantage
rassurés quant aux conditions oui
l'évolution est évidemment de la
pandémie puisqu'on parlait de transats à
l'instant un monsieur roy évidemment
peut pas passer à côté du projet de
transaction l'antre air canada et
transat c'est difficile d'y croire le
contenu du contexte à quoi on peut
s'attendre
écoutez les conditions qui prévalaient
pour que cette entente et lieux sont
toujours les mêmes saisie au niveau
marketing affaires plan d'affaires ce
qu'ils aiment en changer si ces deux
marchés
con qu'on prévoit est difficile encore
pour les deux ou trois prochaines années
donc évidemment la valeur en bourse
souci de transmettre peut-être cette
situation là alors il est fort à parier
que chez air canada on va vouloir être
renégocié les termes de cette entente ci
a toujours lieu d'aller de l'avant
puisque vous parlez d'air canada il ya
entre autres le pdg laquelle no29 yuki
cette semaine disait on veut un
assouplissement des restrictions on veut
que ce soit plus facile
oui c'est ce qu'on disait côté du
gouvernement fédéral
on n'était pas nécessairement prêts mais
l'industrie elle voudrait que ce soit
plus facile de reprendre les activités
vous pensez que c'est possible ça oui
mais en fait c'est pas des industries du
transport est un qui va décider c'est
noémie la santé publique parce que je
pense la priorité c'est s'assurer après
tous ces efforts qui a été fait au
niveau du confinement des mesures qui
ont été prises on vous de l'époque
importés de pays étrangers
le fameux virus donc c'est des autorités
sanitaires est un peu partout d'un monde
qui vont décider de devenir l'industrie
on veut prendre place dans ce débat
c'est au caire du côté du royaume uni
entre eux que des poursuites qui sont
intentées en cours la part des
transporteurs qui critiquent le principe
de la quarantaine d'accords de voyageurs
qui arrivent sur le territoire
est-ce que ça se peut qu'on réussisse à
à marquer le coup ça m'étonnerait
franchement je pense que de l'intérêt
public que général de vaud l'emporté sur
l'intérêt des des transporteurs dans ce
club on sait ce que c'est vous ce que
souhaiteraient les transporteurs en fait
c'est con on maintient une certaine
restriction mais qu on les dirige plutôt
par exemple qu'on interdise l'arrivée de
voyageurs en provenance de zones plus
chaude est ce qu'on pourrait assouplir
les germains assouplir au complet oui je
pense que oui d'ailleurs on voit des
gens en europe certains pays ont
identifié des d'autres pays européens
qui pour lesquelles ces permis de porter
son but du voyage est alors que d'autres
pays qui ont connu peu de difficultés
ces pays d'or sont davantage proscrit
son veut donc interdits d'entrée alors
on peut y aller de cette façon là à
géométrie variable de tri danse on reste
en europe brièvement un monsieur royal à
france ô canada deo kanda c'est un peu
différent le stratégiste gouvernement
fédéral cdd et autres industries et on
peut comprendre ces différents de par
exemple le 11 septembre où les
industries du transport aérien à frapper
directement ici c'est l'ensemble de
l'économie qui est frappée alors si on
arrivait avec une aide dédiée ou aux
transporteurs ou à l'aéronautique bien
il demain les gens du tourisme de
l'hôtellerie
du voyage en général fred hafid pour
obtenir une aide semblable alors je
pense que la stratégie du gouvernement
fédéral et la bonne dose et qu'on ait
tout le monde nos travers des programmes
existants et ensuite si les compagnies
aériennes ont des besoins particuliers
dans les mois à venir mais ils pourront
faire des demandes pour des prêts
garantis des choses comme ça les pertes
seront importantes ça c'est sûr je
remercie beaucoup monsieur je te fait
plaisir à voir
au revoir